hi
so my name is anne rene and i'm a
faculty member in the department of
genetics at stanford university
so i come from france i
went to the economic superior for
college that's in paris
did my grad school at university of nice
still in france
and it's i arrived to america when i did
my postdoc with my greenberg at harvard
medical school
we are very interested in aging
in general so we use different type of
model organism in my lecture i talk
about
the worm cinerabitis elegance because it
lives
very short and can really give us a lot
of
ideas very fast and do genetic screens
for example
for genes or regulators of the aging
process
aging is a really wide open question
that has a lot of societal
but also scientific uh
implications so i think it's a it's
really a fascinating question and
genetics is a great way of a great tool
in fact to
address it probably for someone studying
it can sound
look very daunting like all those big
approaches
so i would sort of like say don't be
scared basically just take one thing
that passionate to
get input from different people and just
dive in it's fun